hi there welcome to another episode of
history of science and technology q a
so i'm happy to try to answer whatever
questions i can about
both modern and less modern history of
science both history of science and
technology that i personally been
involved in people i personally know and
uh
things i've personally seen happen
and things from the more distant past
and particularly about how do things get
to be the way they are today how do
people come to believe the things they
come to believe how does technology come
to exist the way it is um uh right now
um
so a few questions left over from
[Music]
previous times
[Music]
the uh
all right let's see all right i see one
just coming in from i see
asking why are keyboards the default
computer interface
well i'm not sure that's entirely
history i think the okay so there's a
bunch of things to say about this
um
the
how should we interact
with machines
well we could talk to them
we can organize our thoughts let me
let's let's take it sort of further back
into like shortly in a sense we have
thoughts going on in our brains
and we somehow want to communicate those
to machines
or we want to communicate those to other
people
the thing is that the thoughts going on
in one brain with our you know 100
billion neurons or whatever it is in our
brains
they're all different for each different
person and for each different set of
experiences that we have so to kind of
have a a transfer medium to transfer
those thoughts to another person or to a
machine there has to be some
some way of organizing those thoughts
that isn't specific to the details of
a person at the internals of a person's
brain
and the best way we have to do that
right now is with language and human
language i spent lots of effort building
computational language which allows one
to take sort of thoughts that we humans
have and cast them into a form that is
directly understandable by computer but
basically the thing worth realizing is
that there are sort of internal thoughts
going on and then there's some kind of
communication channel which is language
that takes those hundred billion neurons
and has to organize them into something
definite that is in this case human
language
so similarly there's a question of when
we're going to sort of organize our
thoughts to communicate into a computer
what should we do to make that possible
should we you know should we do that by
saying things verbally should we do that
by writing things or typing things
it's not obvious that it's so bad to
type things um and it's particularly
useful i think to have
visual feedback uh well one thing we've
been interested in so when it comes to
computational language
there's a question of can it be spoken
right now wolverine language is a
written language
that we
specify by typing we've thought about
i've thought about quite a bit
is there a spoken version of that that
can be created it needs some new ideas
which we haven't had yet
about you know what's the right way to
take the syntactic structure of a
computational language
and
turn that into the kinds of things that
we're used to saying because when we
speak
in english for example we are making use
of all these parse trees and you know
there's a sentence and it's broken into
a noun phrase a verb phrase a noun
phrase and the verb phrase is but broken
into an adverb and a verb and you know
all kinds of other hierarchical
structure and we managed to do that in
real time from the beginning of the
sentence trying grind through the end of
the sentence
even though it's it's really a a tree
structured kind of hierarchical thing
and somehow we managed to do that and
our brains are set up so that we can
sort of have enough to have these levels
of uh of recursion effectively in the
structure of the sentence i mean it's
pretty easy to make up sentences
where you can't understand them you
can't generate them you know the cat
which sat on the mat which was black
which was this which was that which was
that as it gets too deep more than about
five levels deep
you'll typically just lose it you won't
know what's going on anymore in that
sentence so but in our brains we do
manage to have some recursion depth
in in understanding and generating
sentences and i'm sure there's a way but
haven't figured it out yet to use that
capability to do the same kind of spoken
version of computational language
so
but in any case right now our kind of
best conduit for communicating with
machines
tends to be for anything except sort of
short utterances
tends to or things which are just pure
narrative text tends to be typing on a
keyboard
and i would say that the um
uh there's questions about well it's
very important that we have this kind of
visual feedback of seeing what we type i
mean i i remember
uh well
the yeah that's that's always been sort
of a critical feature of typing things
now you could ask
why this keyboard and not another um why
the qwerty keyboard in at least
english-speaking countries and and not
some other arrangement like the dvorak
keyboard or something like this
my understanding is that in the early
days of typewriters which is where this
keyboard layout came from you know one
issue with a typewriter
is
when you press a key on a typewriter
there's this metal
piece that is the actual thing that has
the the uh the the sort of um the piece
of type on it that's going to hit the
ribbon that's going to press through the
ribbon to the piece of paper and it's
going to make that typed
letter
but the these stalks that you're typing
you're typing with both hands and for
example you don't want
two stalks
to get um that are for nearby letters to
get you know th for example often typed
together and i'm now very confused by
this as i think about it but i'm pretty
sure those are those gosh i have to
think yeah i think those are types of
different hands they're yes they are and
i think they they come from different
sides of the um
uh
of the typewriter you know its
collection of metal stalks
um and so they don't get tangled up i
think there was a certain amount of of
um
uh
kind of
you know
mechanical
uh arrangement to try and arrange that
things were sort of optimized for
uh
sort of mechanical type ability i mean
in general the tradition there back in
by what was the 1830s or something when
samuel morse was inventing morse code
there was some sophistication there in
the idea that um
one would have you know an e was a dot a
t was a dash
um and then uh
like an s is a
is a dot dot dot right and as as the
letters get less common in typical
english they're encoded with longer
sequences of dots and dashes
that was kind of an early example of
data compression um but it was done with
some degree of sophistication i think i
think also amusingly enough there was a
an effort when telegrams were really a
thing
um that uh there was this kind of 140
character limit on telegrams which was
later copied by things like twitter and
so on um as a way to sort of say well
there's you can say a certain amount in
that space so to speak and it was sort
of enough for for saying many kinds of
things but so i think there was some
degree of sophistication in the 1800s uh
by the late 1800s and all the
typewriters stuff was getting
standardized um about sort of how these
things will be arranged i think it's
also a sort of an issue but i don't
think it's well handled in the standard
keyboard of you know um whether you have
to move your fingers and whether you can
uh whether you can type typical words
without moving your fingers and there's
certainly a ways to optimize keyboards
in fact a friend of mine had a company
for a while making cell phone keyboards
for mostly for obscure languages
optimized based on the actual
information theory of kind of uh um
you know which which letter sequences
occur most commonly and which things
should be typed together
for a while i remember in the early
1980s
i remember seeing these chord keyboards
where you would kind of keep your
fingers in a fixed place on the keyboard
and depending on which
chord of keys you pressed that would
correspond to different letters i was
sort of always thought those would catch
on but i think they vanished without
trace
i think also um
stenographers have a system which is
more chord oriented although i don't
know exactly how it works
but so i think that the um
uh the reason that we're you know the
particular keyboards we have right now
are the way they are because that's what
people learn and you know they started
that way for these reasons of mechanics
of typewriters obviously that's not a
thing anymore i had really thought that
there would be more soft keyboards by
now where there's kind of an lcd display
on each key and you're sort of able to
to type based on that but that hasn't
been a thing that has come in very much
i mean there have been some attempts i
have kind of a collection of computers
that didn't make it that i am got at one
time or another and there's one a weird
object where you unfold it and it has a
screen and it has another lcd display
which is its keyboard and i think with
some of these kind of uh electro um
oh gosh what are they the things that uh
where electrical where you can have a
sense of touch based on electrical
effects on the screen
to give you something which is kind of
like a virtual keyboard in terms of feel
although probably without the nice
clicks
clicking uh
sensation
but you know that they're obviously on
phones and with uh
oh i don't know there's what is a touch
bar or something on on
macs and so on they've been attempts to
make soft keyboards um that uh you know
phones it's kind of a necessary thing as
far as it goes
but i think uh this idea that you would
sort of press a shift key and it would
suddenly go to a different keyboard um
is not has not been such such a thing
but um
uh yeah so i mean i you know will
will voice you know at various times
people say voice it's going to come in
voice is going to be everywhere and
voice is useful for some things but
there's plenty of things it's not useful
for and i tend to think that the extra
kind of moment of thinking that comes
with actually typing something may
actually be helpful in formulating one's
thoughts just as as i was mentioning
earlier kind of the raw tumble of of of
neuron firings isn't what we use for
actual language we organize our thoughts
to communicate them with language
let's see
the questions here
about
why didn't someone aaron asks why didn't
someone invent the printing press
earlier
it seems to have been quite financially
valuable was an engineering problem or
lack of entrepreneurship i don't know
that full history i mean i do know
that
uh
the idea of movable type
which is this notion i mean one thing is
kind of making the potato
cut the potato print thing where you are
carving out something and then you're
using that to make kind of a stamp
obviously people had stamps
forever because that was the thing you
know the king seal or whatever was a
stamp in ceiling wax or something like
that but um uh this this notion that you
could have a stamp and it was kind of a
carved out stamp and you could go you
know put it even in ink and stamp it out
that was a thing that was around from
antiquity i think
um the the idea of movable type the idea
that you would have you know i remember
when i was a kid
uh
using an actual um
uh letter press
uh i guess that's the american name for
it um had a different name in british
english which i now not sure quite what
it was actually but but um you know back
in the day right you would have these
pieces of lead type each letter was a
piece of lead type
um in a uh
um and uh you know when you when you
were making separation between lines you
get these pieces of lead that's why it's
called leading between between lines you
stick a piece of lead in between these
two lines of type and you would always
you'd have these these frames where you
you set the type is usually upside down
usually put the put the letters in sort
of from the first line in in upside down
first and it's always kind of fun
because you would have the lower case
and the uppercase of letters and that's
why it's called uppercase and lowercase
um and uh you know the e was always the
biggest um
uh
piece of of um of of type
um and of of um font characters and then
you know the z was a small one and so on
you pick them all out and you arrange
them and sometimes you'd have to put you
know you
tie them with strings so that you keep
them uh from falling out and then you
put them in uh in an actual uh printing
device and then you know you'd have this
this sort of plate of of um
um
of uh
of of of lead type
and then you'd uh you know then you
it sort of goes on a piece of ink and
then it goes down on a piece of paper
and that's how you could print things it
was really really worked quite nicely
but that that idea of movable type of
being able to take individual pieces of
type
and set them um and uh to be able to
print from
i don't know why that idea didn't
originate earlier it's certainly the
notion of sort of carving out pieces of
lead
um certainly should have existed i don't
think there was any precision
engineering that was needed you know the
lead didn't fit together perfectly
letters a nice soft metal so you could
you know squash it and get the things to
sort of
form correctly
i would say that the the big innovation
that was from the early part of the um
uh let's see that must have been 1930s
ish
was photolithography so originally when
you would set type you would be like
every every letter would be individually
picked out and you you set the type and
you print whatever you print and you
take it all apart again and put the
pieces of type back in there in their
upper and lower cases so to speak and um
and you recycle them for another for
another day by the way i mean in in
in old books when they were printed
people would regularly you know they
they print them off pretty slowly and so
when there was a typo that was noticed
people would just go in and pull out
that piece of lead type and put in
another one and then keep printing i
remember years ago
i was sort of curious about this because
i was considering buying an original
edition of newton's principia from 1687
and
as sort of a question of well there were
about i think 1500 copies of that book
are thought to have been printed and
maybe 500 of them have known locations
in today's world 300 and something 350
years later
um the um uh but but so
what there's sort of a question of when
those 1500 copies were printed
in what order were they printed because
in the in the kind of uh
concept of things like the antiquarian
book world you know if you if your copy
was printed very early in the print run
then it's more valuable than one that
was printed you know systematically
later
and the thing that was kind of confusing
was when it was printed
that they would print out all these
different sheets and then when they
bound it they would potentially take a
sheet that was printed early that was
for page three and a sheet that was
printed later that was page four and so
on and so it seemed like there wasn't a
kind of systematic this was printed
before that by the way it's always
charming to see in these old books
um they will have you know like um uh it
says uh you know this is a book printed
by so-and-so and it's sold on this
particular place in you know paternoster
row in london and things like this you
know you can you can buy it but
be behind the church in such and such a
place and so on very very specific and
that's sort of the tradition that led
people in kind of citation styles to say
you know
published by you know the way they would
instead of just saying you know addison
wesley publishing company or something
they would say you know reading
massachusetts addison wesley publishing
company and i think that was kind of a
holdover from the days when of really
old books
where would be like you buy it from the
specific guy with a stall in this
particular place
um and uh it's sort of funny by the time
there are these global publishing
companies and you're still listing you
know reading massachusetts is the
location as if somebody would go there
to actually get this book
i remember when i was actually with that
specific publishing company alison
wesley when we were publishing the first
edition of the mathematica book i
remember talking to some people there
and saying have you ever actually seen
the printing press that prints these
things oh no no we've been working in
publishing for 30 years we've never
actually seen a printing press so you
know times change
but um in any case the big innovation
of i think the 1930s was
photolithography
the ability to
have
a
uh instead of setting type
one one letter at a time to be able to
have essentially a photographic
representation uh essentially a
photograph and then to use
that photography to do
lithography as in
you you basically you take that that
photograph and it's a picture of the
page you want to make
and then it's something where you etch
away a plate
in every place where they're for example
where it isn't black in the thing that
uh well you want to etch it away
where it
yeah where it isn't black
um on the thing you're trying to
print so that means you're etching it
away so the parts that are etched away
aren't raised the parts that aren't
etched away are raised and so when you
put it in ink you'll get those raised
parts with the things that pick up the
ink and the things you print
and so that was kind of what allowed you
to have sort of from a picture
to to printing um by doing that kind of
etching with acid
based on you would have something that
is is light sensitive and then you etch
it away with acid it's the same process
that's used in
in uh lithography for um
uh
um
uh for making microprocessors
where we are etching away layers of
silicon
rather to create a kind of circuit
rather than etching away
um
layers of your printing plate i guess
that's what's called offset printing and
i'm or lithography but i'm not quite
sure why
i don't actually know why it's called
offset printing um but in any case the i
mean before that time when there were
illustrations in books
they would typically be things like wood
cuts and wood cuts are you take a piece
of wood and you chisel out the parts
that aren't supposed to print and then
you
you know put it in ink and you and you
uh you know print it in the book so to
speak
so that was uh kind of the um
um
um
the the um
um
[Music]
let's see the the um
uh
um
that that's kind of um
uh the the concept there now i mean in
in um
uh i can say
and
by the way someone said said here that
it's called offset printing because the
image doesn't go directly
from
the like in a letterpress or something
directly from the thing you set to the
paper but it's transferred to some other
surfaces and intermediary um i i have
certainly seen printing presses i've
i've seen the ones that uh for example
um haven't seen the one the nks book was
printed on but i have seen ones that uh
we've used for printing other kinds of
things i mean the other well
i mean just to say a little bit more
about printing technology um big thing
is four color printing or six color
printing or whatever else
the idea is you can break down any color
for for colors made with light
red green blue are the primary colors
the complements of those colors cyan
magenta yellow and well cyan magenta and
yellow are the are the colors relevant
for ink for light that is going to be
reflected rather than light that's going
to be emitted and so sort of the way
that people make
uh sort of
color printing is done with cyan magenta
yellow and black and if you look under
magnifying glass or something you'll see
this
this little detailed pattern and what
happens is there's an array of dots that
are associated with each color and
they're at different angles and there
are three non-commensurate angles
that um so that you end up getting
something which has a nice uniform
covering of dots if those angles were
wrong you'd get moire patterns and you
would start seeing these these sort of
weird effects but you don't see that
because those angles are non-commands
and you see um and also there's this
notion of screening so so in a typical
book oh i can't remember i think the nks
book was printed with a much finer
screen like 150
um
lines per inch screen which means when
you turn the color into dots
how far apart are those dots
um and
that's something where different kinds
of printing do it differently and
usually what happens is sometimes with
fancy magazines you'll have six color
printing where in addition to cyan
magenta yellow you'll have a few other
colors sometimes you also have so-called
spot colors
where as well as those so-called process
colors the ones that to which into which
any red green blue can be broken you
also have oh i'm really you know my
corporate color is purple i'm going to
print with a spot color of purple and
just have a great big you know nice
bar of solid purple not made from a
combination of
of
red and blue for example from the dots
um i don't in fact know exactly when uh
four color
printing came in i guess
it became really popular by well by the
time magazines were being printed in
1930s 1940s things like that
a lot of printing equipment
uh sort of
the previous generation of printing
equipment a lot of it dated from the
1940s and so on
but um
i will say
in terms of um
um
uh well there was this question the
original question was why wasn't why
weren't printing presses invented
earlier i don't know i don't think they
were engineering i don't think there was
a big engineering issue
there may have been issues with uh well
certainly questions about
why would one want to do this how would
one do it et cetera et cetera et cetera
for a while i mean in many places
the
printing was thought to be a very
dangerous technology because it's like
if you can print you can you know print
things and and pin them on every church
door or whatever you can print something
and make many copies of it and that
allows you to disseminate information in
a more efficient way and it has been
well sadly or happily depending on how
you look at it it's been a feature
throughout history that governments have
tended to
be nervous about people disseminating
information
um the uh um and um
it's because it's like who's in charge
here type thing
but um uh i think the um so the printing
press was for a long time
something where you kind of had to have
a license to operate a printing press
and uh people would be
and there were things where like for
example in england i think
there were just specific places like i
think oxford and cambridge is university
presses but the only places that were
licensed to print the bible um and uh
but it was something where there was
where there was a a lot of sort of
licensing around it i mean it's it's you
know it's funny how these things change
over time it's like at different times
like you know you still have to have a
fancy license i think it's become a
little less fancy these days to operate
like a television station or a radio
station in the us
um and you know in in china you'd have
to have a license to run a website and
you know with a government
identification number and all those
kinds of things it it's it's been
different in different places at
different times but time was when when
to operate a printing press you had to
have kind of a license from the
government
i think that the um uh so i don't know
exactly how that played into the
development of early printing and it's
and it's spreading but uh that's a
little bit on printing i i should tell a
little bit of a story about printing
um a uh
a place where i got to know more about
it than i might have ever wanted to know
when i wrote this big book new kind of
science that came out almost 20 years
ago now
um
the uh the book involves a lot of very
high resolution pictures and we wanted
to get these nice cellular automaton
pictures
printed at very high resolution and so
we had sort of very exacting
specifications for the paper and the
printing press and so on
and
turned out
we were using a technology there that
was really quite a new technology which
was so-called direct-to-plate printing
where instead of using a film where you
would have uh sort of a photographic
image of the page and you would do this
you know expose it to light and do this
etching and all that kind of thing
instead direct to plate printing was
like
was basically a laser as a laser that
scans a plate
much like
a laser printer has that kind of uh
scanning
um
idea
for um uh uh in in the case of um uh
um you know so locally for the laser
printer but this is now scanning a plate
that is going to be the plate that's
used for printing
and um so we were using that technology
i actually have a bunch of the plates
that we used for the nks books sitting
somewhere in my archive there are these
big
okay so that they're two kinds of two
fundamental kinds of printing
sheet fed presses and so-called web
presses which have nothing to do with
the world wide web their web called web
presses for a different reason
sheet fed presses you basically print
some number a signature of pages maybe
16 pages at a time and they there's a
big plate that has all those pages laid
out and you have a big sheet of paper
and you print it and you get uh you get
all those pages printed and then to make
the book you cut those pages up and you
well you actually fold them up usually
and then you stitch them into the book
so to speak or you glue them into the
book that's sheet fed press and they're
sort of page at a time you know
signature at a time printing a web press
involves a continuous stream of paper
and these are giant machines
that i guess they use to print
newspapers as well but they're also used
to print print books
and it's a giant machine where there's
paper going and i don't know 200 miles
an hour or something through this
machine and it's printing printing
printing and it really doesn't make
sense to do a print run like that unless
you're printing a decent number a few
thousand copies or something um and once
you have it sort of launched it's going
to print that stuff and it'll all be
done in a in a very short amount of time
but those are kind of the two principal
technologies i think that end up getting
used so for example the nks book was
sort of unusual
in you know popular books where there
were quite large print runs in in being
done on a sheet fed press because you
have a lot more control on a sheet fed
press if you see oh this thing is too
light on one side let's put more ink on
that side of the of the printing plate
you can do that but with a web press
you know it's going the paper is going
at 200 miles an hour and you've printed
the whole book by the time you even
thought about adjusting the the flow of
ink or something
so so anyway it was it was being printed
on sheet tread press using this
technology of direct-to-plate printing
um
laser direct-to-plate printing okay all
great and it was being printed at a
printing company in canada it's a very
common place to do uh
high quality printing either in canada
or in the far east um
the
uh it's it's some
um
the uh
so you know we're ready to do this but
with
with director plate printing
one wasn't able to get the same kind of
proofs
that one could get with uh with this
sort of film-based printing where you'd
get you know you'd see something that
was printed from the film and then it
would get transferred to the plate and
then it would be printed and so on so
anyway we we sent a person
up to canada to go look at the plates
just to check them before they were
going to get printed and
it's um
a good and careful person and he said
well actually this plate
this particular cellular automaton image
which he knew was supposed to be a
symmetrical or left right symmetrical
image it's not left right symmetrical on
this plate
how could that be
and so big kind of
big kind of uh help how much has gone
wrong here kind of thing so we look into
this
and um it was actually over a holiday
weekend in um
uh
um
in 2002 this was all happening
um and uh it was a big sort of big sort
of uh problem
um because you know how many of these
plates were going to be wrong how could
we even get the plate correct what had
happened et cetera et cetera et cetera
and um it was kind of interesting
because
uh the um the company
that well i forget how but somehow i got
in touch with the
cto of the company that made the
direct-to-plate printing system
and also it was it was a system that ran
through postscript
and i also had known that the founders
of adobe creative postscript and i got
in touch with with with one of them two
and said hey what's going on
and uh the the person who made the kind
of raster was responsible for the kind
of laser raster system say oh it must be
a bug in our laser raster
you know kind of system
uh because that was the piece he'd made
and the postscript people said well
maybe it's a bug in postscript turns out
it was a bug in postscript and it had
been there for like a decade and it was
a bug because people weren't used to
making very high resolution kind of
raster images that weren't photographs
usually they were photographs with sort
of continuous gradation of colors but
when you're making the solar automaton
image there's black white black white at
the full resolution of the image and
that was something that wasn't correctly
accounted for in a version of the
so-called image operator and postscript
so it was kind of a kind of a remarkable
thing that one sort of had to drill all
the way down to get um uh to get that
information and so we got the bug we we
worked around the bug and and the book
was printed correctly and it's all good
and and they're just uh i think i have a
copy of the plate that um was the one
before the glitch was fixed so to speak
but anyway the the um
uh the thing that um uh actually when we
when we printed the nks book we printed
a bunch of copies uh maybe a hundred
thousand copies initially and then then
turned out we needed more and that was i
forget all the details of this that was
a
maybe that was
let's see that was that was all
happening in a in a very elaborate way
at some time that was very inconvenient
in in the summer of of the early summer
of 2002
and the encased book came out on may
14th so
um sometime around then
in any case the um uh it was kind of
interesting to know the supply chain for
for the book
because we had picked this particular
kind of paper it's called finch vhf very
very fine paper or something and it came
from a paper mill in upstate new york
which i think
came from trees
that words like you know this book is
going to come from trees well those
actual trees were somewhere in upstate
new york and it was a particular kind of
kind of
tree that was turning into this kind of
paper through a paper mill in upstate
new york
and then it was actually being printed
the book was being printed in winnipeg
canada
um and uh then it was being bound in
toronto
and then it had to make its way to the
distribution centers for amazon and
barnes and noble and folks like that
which were in places like memphis
tennessee
and so there was this big claim of oh it
just can't be done we can't get
sort of the um uh you know we can't get
books to this place quickly enough and
so on so i i am this is my one moment of
doing sort of operations research kinds
of things it's like how far is it to go
by truck from here to there when can we
get a slot in the schedule for the
binding
place for the bindery etc etc etc and so
the book made its way from raw paper in
upstate new york
to printing in winnipeg to binding in
toronto to distribution in memphis and
somehow that was all achieved with um
there was some other issue with uh but i
remember working out the trucking
distances and all kinds of all kinds of
issues like that because one feature of
books is they're pretty big and by the
time you're talking about tens hundreds
of thousands of books that's a lot of
truck volume uh to move around the place
um and so uh i'm afraid i have to say
that that um
uh i won't name the retailer right now
but um there was a a sad feature of the
nks book as it was sort of climbing on
best seller lists and things you kind of
have to keep the momentum sales going
and you have to feed the distribution
channel and a retailer whose name i i i
won't specifically mention managed to
lose a complete
uh container of books that the complete
um or no a complete semi-truck worth of
books for like a week um and exactly how
you lose a thing like that is unclear to
me um but uh it was uh something that
happened because you know when you when
you when you make these things they they
tell you you know label them i don't
know how it works right now because they
haven't done something like this
recently but you know it's like label it
with the right barcodes and things and
it will arrive at a loading dock and um
uh you know then then it'll get unpacked
and hopefully go off and get distributed
and so on but uh kind of kind of a shame
because otherwise we would have we would
have peaked higher on the best seller
lists by a significant amount i think it
had had a had a whole container of books
not been lost and not made it through
the distribution channel at that time
with the right momentum so to speak to
to the sort of peak in in that time in
those lists uh like that
okay
let's see
oh my
um
all right there's a question here from
memes
in my opinion if physics hadn't worked
out for professor feinman would he have
been able to make it as a stand-up comp
comedian
you know i'm i'm i'm not enough of an
expert in in stand-up comedy so i i
i am
i i don't think i could give a really
informed opinion of that
um i think uh
um
dick feynman was always a
a um
a good presenter and a good explainer of
things and he also liked doing he was
quite the thespian i i never saw him in
and you know he would he would be uh
have various kinds of parts and student
plays at caltech and so on i have to say
i never i never i never went to a single
one of those players so i don't can't
can't speak to his um uh thespian uh
qualities and abilities
um i think uh
um
it wasn't um i will say
that um in terms of sort of pop culture
i don't think dick feinman was quite as
up on that as as people might have been
um i have to say i remember this one
terrible incident where
um
there's the theoretical physics seminar
actually probably one that i organized
at caltech this must have been 1981
two-ish
type time frame
and um uh dick tymon had a terrible
habit
um of sort of trying to figure out what
the what the magic flaw i mean in fact
he had this competition going with me to
try and find sort of who could figure
out the the the the fatal flaw
in what was being said first
um
and anyway
one of these was
seminars was going on
and uh
um
uh
dick feinman her friend who's also a
friend of mine uh rick field
um
who um and somehow i don't know that
dick fireman and rickfield had been
discussing
uh somehow they were describing things
in terms of turkeys and people being
kind of turkeys and as in kind of
you know
not getting it kind of dumb and so on
and so uh
but dick feinman didn't know that the
term turkey was a general term for
you know
you know being dumb type thing
so anyways one of these talks
uh at some moment he says to rick field
and quite uh sort of in in in plain
uh you know audible form
you know something like it's time to
pass the the uh the cranberry sauce
thinking that that was kind of an
encoded version of i think this guy you
know this person is a turkey
of course it wasn't so encoded because
in you know knowledge of pop culture
would reveal that you know the turkey
idea was was a very popular meaning so
to speak so i'm afraid that was a that
was a a dick fireman not quite in touch
with the memes of the day
uh kind of thing and i think um
he uh i mean he was certainly somebody
who liked
uh particularly in his earlier years
like the kind of prankish type of thing
i would say he was not
a um
uh you know a telling jokes i'm trying
to remember whether i ever heard him
oh my gosh let me think about this for a
second
um i mean he would he would sometimes
imitate people who he thought were um uh
you know he was not a uh
he wasn't um
um
i would say that uh
uh he would tend to make fun of kind of
the experts saying
these very erodic things and not
understanding the core point and i'm
afraid one of the persons people he
would often make fun of was murray
gilman uh the person who invented corks
who had an office sort of right next
door with an assistant in between the
two of them but but um to him for many
many years and murray was a very kind of
erudite you know pronounce every word
perfectly and dick feinman was
definitely the the you know corsa new
york brooklyn type accent type person
and murray would always be be expressing
these these these uh sort of names from
other languages in these very carefully
pronounced ways and and dick feinman
would always make fun of this
and and imitate murray and um and sort
of uh imitate some some strange you know
thing where he would sort of claim that
murray was was making some some sound
which was you know involved you sort of
spitting everything out to make this
sound or something like this
so he would tend to make terrible fun of
of um sort of the erudite so to speak
and i think he he always believed in
kind of um uh breaking things down into
their sort of simplest parts
uh i kind of
like that too
um the uh but i think he was his
uh patience for for sort of the erudite
and the expert was was never very high
and he would he would certainly imitate
uh things that people would say um which
were you know where they were um
you know he would talk about things i
don't know he'd been on a textbook
commission
uh for example and he was very um
unhappy about uh you know people telling
him uh i can't remember the specifics of
you know but professor feinman nobody
will understand that and he would sort
of explain that in a very uh
in a way where he was kind of imitating
the way he was not he was not a great
mimic um but he certainly it was amusing
that he would sort of try and give the
um the full kind of um version of uh of
what was said as an imitation so to
speak so i would say my my overall
rating would be uh great expositor of
science not great stand-up comedian but
i'm not really completely sure what what
it takes to be a great stand-up comedian
um
okay a couple of questions here one from
frost
question is
how much science and technology isn't
published or publicly available is the
most advanced science in the published
literature and in patents and things
like that are there branches of science
that are secret
um
you know am i personally sitting on any
such things or know about ones that are
not kind of public facing
that's kind of changed over time i mean
i think that
the world has sort of
become more you know with the web and
who knows what even live streaming and
all these kinds of things
a lot
has become more visible than it once was
i mean back in the day and it's also the
case that there's a question of who's
sort of leading
in the science and technology charge and
you know for when governments have been
leading the charge as happened in the
time of the second world war and and the
in the kind of the sputnik era um up
through the cold war so to speak up to
the substantial part of the cold war
there was a lot more tendency for the
greatest science to be
kind of uh sort of proprietary of
government so to speak and and secret
and so on um i think in in these days
there tends to be a lot more kind of
companies that um
you know it tends to be more in the
corporate sector and more in the let me
show off at all about all the wonderful
things we have rather than let's keep it
secret and only use it when we're in a
war or something um so i don't know
um
it's uh
um
uh
you know over time
uh you know different countries have
different uh rules about what has to be
kept secret and whether if you know
something that's secret like if in
britain there's the official secrets act
where you know if you know something
that's secret uh even if you didn't you
know get a security clearance and make a
contract that says you keep things
secret you have to keep things secret it
works a little differently in the u.s
um but over time it's sort of been
interesting to see sometimes i i know
about things that are sort of uh secret
for a while and um uh either
you know more often in the corporate
sector um and uh i would say that the
the sort of turnover time of things not
being secret anymore seems to be uh you
know it's it's rather short these days
and i don't know maybe i'm just ignorant
of uh sort of uh major
sort of troves of of secret science now
there are things that sometimes get done
like uh one that's often discussed is
public key cryptography and uh was that
invented by the um
uh
for example gchq the the british um uh
single intelligence folk um the um
uh
you know
it's a little complicated i i don't know
the answer to that but it's a little
complicated because sometimes these
things things can be invented but nobody
knows their significance and so you go
back later and you say look it was
invented there
but the whole sort of thing around it
wasn't invented and so you know somebody
can say well so and so invented this
thing in some deep and some secret
government
uh situation and that thing would have
turned into facebook or something but
guess what it couldn't be deployed as
facebook when it's deep in some secret
government thing so it didn't turn into
facebook so to speak
so i i don't know to what extent those
kinds of things have happened
um i think that in in modern times
the uh
uh well it's complicated because there
are you talk about patents there are
classified patterns
um patents where there is some sort of
statement of of who invented it but the
patent is not uh out there in the open
literature i don't completely know the
status of those in the modern times uh
for a while there was quite a lot of
activity around those things in in areas
like cryptography
um but uh
um the
the question of of is there sort of a
a um
uh for example in
you know it's complicated that the sort
of
for example
do we even have sort of big areas of
science and so on that we're not kind of
putting out in public view
at different times in my life i have had
such things um
the uh for example when i was working on
my whole new kind of science book that
was about a decade of
being of disappearing from public view
because i wanted to kind of concentrate
on doing that piece of work and at that
time it was invisible and people would
try and sort of find out what was going
on and did some rather scoreless things
in in the process of doing that um and i
was like i just want to concentrate on
this just leave me alone i'm just you
know just private citizen doing a bunch
of weird science just leave me alone
until it's finished
um
in more modern times i've do have been
doing sort of the opposite thing of kind
of live streaming our working sessions
and it's kind of pretty much all visible
and i would say there's there's
at most weeks delay between uh and
sometimes one day delay between sort of
if it if it's something being done
you know notebooks that i've created
sort of get posted on the web by the
next morning type thing so that's a very
very short turnaround i think that the
the notion of kind of core pieces of
things that are more basic science
being sort of not in the public view
that has tended to become i think it
tends to be the case that they are in
the public view for better or worse i
mean sometimes there's kinds of science
where people can do terrible things by
by knowing that science you know here's
how to make this nasty kind of kind of
thing
um and uh everybody knows how to do it
and that's it's a complicated issue
whether
uh you know to what extent sort of the
uh the it's it's good for the world to
sort of have all that information be
widely available and to what since it
isn't and in some cases like for example
nuclear weapons uh it's it's not really
enough to know you know how do you make
an implosion lens you've also got to get
your
uranium-235 or whatever and the supply
chain to get that is not an easy one
but there are other cases of
technologies where once you sort of know
how to do it
it's um um it's it's something much more
readily doable
all right let's see
uh there's a question here from h
t
uh from tyler why is the turing machine
model so dominant
today in theory of computation compared
to the equivalent lambda calculus
well i know this history fairly well he
says famous last words
the um
this all has to do with kind of the
origins of um
uh
um
of the idea of universal computation
and
it's a big idea
and it's an idea that people almost had
multiple times you know gottfried
leibniz almost had it in the very late
1600s he got pretty close i don't think
he actually had the idea but you know he
was writing all these notes you know all
the time about different things he was
thinking of and he was definitely
circling around that with his
characteristic universe solace and
things like this but the idea of there
is a fixed machine
and it is capable of just being given
different starting conditions
essentially different programming and
then do different uh do arbitrary
different operations he didn't have that
really although he was sort of circling
around it
uh charles babbage uh with his
analytical engine
uh and ada lovelace with her kind of
understanding at a more abstract level
of the analytical engine they sort of
almost had it in the 1830s
um
and uh
then um
but that kind of
kind of disappeared
and then in uh
i think the first place it really
appeared formally was in the work of
moses schoenfinkel in 1920 with
combinators but that work
is very abstract it was kind of this
idea of we know that you know the nand
operation is a way of making any logic
expression let's make these symbols s
and k that can be combined in all
different ways to make arbitrary
expressions in predicate calculus
in uh
and that's sort of in a sense to do
arbitrary computations the problem is
that sean finkel was an ultra minimalist
he got rid of the idea of variable he
didn't have variables and he had these
just these two symbols s and k and you
put them together you can do arbitrary
computations i just wrote in fact even a
book about combinators recently uh
trying to understand a hundred years
later how this all works and combinators
are very obscure and combinators
the core ideas of combinators with
symbolic computation transformation
rules universal computation these ideas
actually i personally have made great
use of them in language design many of
those ideas have not been widely used
elsewhere the idea the final idea of
sean finkel's of removal mention of
variables
just makes something that us humans just
have a really hard time understanding
and uh so that that was 1920. sean
finkel did his thing it nobody really
paid attention to it a person called
haskell curry came along a few years
later and sort of rediscovered what sean
finkel had done and he gradually
understood what had been done
and um that um turned into curry's
combinatory logic but by the time
and that was that sort of was one of the
strands of doing universal computational
although not a terribly popular one
although haskell curry it turns out was
quite involved in the war effort and in
early computers and i gather actually
wrote this thing about why functional
about sort of pre-functional programming
based on his experience with combinators
but it was never taken up
and instead the von neumann kind of
procedural programming idea
with variables and and sort of sequences
of instructions and things was taken up
okay so we're back 1920 moses sean
finkel 1931 kurt godel kurt godel
needed a way to represent sort of
arbitrary operations and encode them in
arithmetic essentially write a compiler
that goes from arbitrary things like the
statement this statement is unprovable
compiling that down to arithmetic and
for that he used a trick
this these things called general
recursive functions
so recursive functions
had been kind of invented well fibonacci
in 1202 had an early example of
recursion and people had invented the
fibonacci idea much earlier than that in
in studies of prozadie in in um in india
and things like that probably and even
in antiquity but in any case the the
idea of recursion was one that was sort
of around and then in the in the early
part in in the 1900-ish time frame
people around david hilbert had kind of
thought well we'll formalize so what
counts as a mathematically constructable
function and it will be primitive
recursion primitive recursion means you
can uh a function can depend on earlier
values but it can't do kind of some kind
of while loop looking for future values
but what godel did was he invented
general recursive functions which can
have that so-called mu operator that
goes and sort of looks for future values
and he used general recursive functions
in the proof of girdle's theorem in 1931
and that was another place where sort of
something which turns out to be capable
of universal computation was invented so
that's 1931.
then 1935 alonzo church
uh is working on lambda calculus so
lambda calculus
is a way of taking
so people had the idea of a function f
of x is x squared things like that
people have the idea of a mathematical
function
um people around uh well first fraga in
the 1880s
and then piano 1890s ish
then whitehead and russell 1910
all these people had had kind of the
idea that you could sort of abstract the
pure function if f of x
is x squared what is f itself
and f itself is just this pure function
that is something where you can what is
that well they wrote it as with iotas
and epsilons and so on and church
ended up picking the symbol lambda to
represent sort of the pure function
and church really developed that that
theory and eventually wrote a paper
called an unsolvable problem of number
theory in which what he was doing was to
encode see the the interest at that time
was
people wondered what is mathematics
and people like hilbert had said
mathematics is just a formal system
where in the end you can break it down
into the set of axioms and these formal
rules that describe what you do with
axioms
and so that was kind of the idea um
around that time that was then taken up
by whitehead and russell um to just turn
all of mathematics into something purely
in terms of logic or purely in a sense
structural um
that that was kind of the notion there
was some
can we take mathematics as mathematics
is practiced and break it down into this
kind of fundamental pieces and that was
kind of the motivation for many of these
things for sean finkel it was the
motivation for church
it was the motivation indirectly well
effectively for godel and so on was the
motivation for all these people was to
find this these ways to sort of
formalize mathematics and break it down
into something whereas hilbert would say
you didn't really even have to be
talking about mathematics is the formal
system you could be talking about tables
and chairs instead of numbers and and
plus signs and so on
um i actually think and have recently
come to the conclusion that the idea of
breaking mathematics down in this kind
of axiomatic way is actually a mistake
and the wrong direction and um it's uh i
kind of
have finally and very circuitous route
have come to the belief which i'll
probably talk about bunch more in the
next month or two about um the fact that
mathematics does mathematicians practice
it is kind of like imagine that all the
possible truths of mathematics are like
the the like sort of collisions of
molecules in a gas
mathematics says mathematicians practice
it it's kind of like the fluid dynamics
of what's going on of looking at large
scale flows and vortices and things like
that
breaking things down into axioms is
is kind of like the molecular dynamics
looking at things at the level of
individual molecules bouncing around and
there are occasionally cases where you
dive down to the molecular level but the
big picture of mathematics is not at
that level in any case the the idea from
hilbert and whitehead and russell and so
on is let's go down to the macular
dynamics
okay so in that tradition came alan
turing in 1936
um writing a paper um on uh
let's see on the
on the insidents problem which is the
decision problem which is the question
of uh something that was formulated
around the hilbert i think probably
formulated it and people around him
developed it um
that was kind of the idea of given a
statement in let's say number theory or
something can you decide that it is true
in some mechanical kind of way
and um and so
uh what
what turing wanted to do was to say no
you can't decide it's true in a
mechanical way and for that
he produced this much more concrete
version of sort of a device for doing
mathematics which was a turing machine
you know church had lambda calculus as a
device for doing mathematics sean finkel
had combinators um
girdle had general recursive functions
all these people had essentially devices
for doing mathematics
but touring's one was much easier to
understand than the others
and and was the one that eventually
became very popular now at the time
nobody knew
first of all it became clear fairly
quickly that all these different sort of
devices for representing mathematics
were equivalent
nobody knew
that those things were what our universe
could do
people thought even godel thought i
think turing thought
um turing suspected
that
uh human minds for example were not like
turing machines or general recursive
functions they were capable of doing
more
uh girdle has a footnote where he talks
about
how you know human minds can decide
things that can't be decided uh by the
saxomatic system he's set up and talks
about you know a hierarchy of types
ramified into the transfinite and so on
that's kind of a an obscure kind of idea
for um for how that might work but any
case the the um
the thing that um was was not clear at
the time not clear back in the 1930s and
so on is if these things were universal
and they all turned out to be equivalent
what did it mean to be universal
were these things actually
um
uh kind of
universal at the level
of that's all you could possibly make or
were they simply
what this particular framework of
mathematics could provide
i don't think it was until the 1980s and
actually i think it was my own efforts
that really highlighted the idea of what
could you make in the physical universe
what kinds of computation could our
physical universe actually do
and people who believe physicists for
example had believed for a long time
that well there's touring machines but
when it comes to the physical universe
we're solving differential equations
even alan turing late in his life in
1952 or so
when he started writing papers about
morphogenesis and reaction diffusion
equations in biology he was like well
that's physics that's not like a turing
machine
that's like
partial differential equations and exact
uh
real numbers and things like this
and so that was had been really the
belief of of people in kind of the
mathematical sciences
and i think in the 1980s i pushed pretty
hard to to understand that there was
sort of this computational view of
things i wasn't sure that
that there would be a ready description
of our whole dynamics of physics in
computational terms but what i did think
was true was that anything that we
humans could realistically observe would
be turnable into something which was
computational that if we were going to
define an experiment that we could
represent symbolically and think about
with our minds that that would end up
being something that would have a sort
of discrete description that could be
made computational so to speak it's only
very recently with our project to find a
fundamental theory of physics that i'm
now
you know absolutely convinced
that the the universe is computational
all the way down
and equivalent to a turing machine so to
speak all the way down but the the
historical dynamics is people understood
turing machines better than they
understood these other things they were
different communities i mean there was a
lambda calculus community there was even
a small combinators community and these
people were using those models and they
were kind of oh we don't do turing
machines we do we do lambda calculus and
even even today i for my book about
combinators we made a bibliography of
sort of all papers that have been
written about combinators that sort of
overlaps with the lambda calculus world
there's a whole world of lambda calculus
and combinators that separate from the
turing machine world
but in the 1950s
when people started to
think about kind of
uh well okay so what happened there was
there's another reason why turning
machines won out actually
here's why so 1950s people were starting
to think about artificial intelligence
and how would
how would um uh how would brains be
correspond to these electrical machines
that were being invented in computers
well there was an important link which
was mcculloch and pitts warren mcculloch
and walter pitts
1943 i think
wrote their paper about kind of well
neural networks the original neural
networks paper trying to idealize sort
of a neural net in terms of something
like an electrical machine
and they imagined that we were our
brains were set up like electrical
machines with switching equipment and so
on
in the in the past in the early few
decades there have been work
on uh kind of the way to think about uh
people have built electrical machines
electrical networks electric circuits
there were switches there was starting
to there were there were um devices like
triodes from vacuum tubes that were
switches that were pure electronic
switches um where you know you put
current in one you put a voltage on one
thing and it's a gate that determines
whether current can flow through that
that was originally triodes later on uh
transistors um were what was used to do
that but so there was this idea of
switching networks and claude shannon
had figured out this correspondence
between boolean algebra um and and
switching networks and so on and there
was this idea that was sort of emerging
of automata finite automata these things
where there were a finite number of
states of the system that were defined
by open the switch close that switch and
so on
into that tradition came a color
competes with their kind of model of the
nervous system and they uh pointed right
back to touring and said look there's
this touring machine thing and oh by the
way it has this universality property
which turing originally proved in the
context specifically of turing machines
he produced a universal turing machine
that was universal in the sense that it
could represent any other turing machine
he didn't know at that well he actually
knew at that point that it could also
represent lambda calculus but um all
these other different forms of models of
computation were were found uh to be
equivalent later in any case so
mcculloch and pits point to touring
machines they say it's equivalent to
turing machines
and um
that's um
uh that that that's the way that um
and and so then turing machines kind of
become
the this standard thing to talk about
when people are talking about artificial
intelligence
and people are thinking about
automata
and finite automata
um then eventually cellular automata but
turing machines i think through that
route through mcculloch and pitts kind
of became the standard thing to talk
about there's a famous book from 1956
about um automata studies i think it's
called um edited by
john mccarthy marvin minsky some of
those folk i think claude shannon maybe
also um that was sort of a founding
document of sort of theoretical
artificial intelligence and it's very
full of turing machines like there's a
paper in there by claude shannon showing
that you can in principle make a
universal turing machine with just two
states but it has to have a lot of
symbols on its tape actually as i found
um in the end uh you know i came up with
this turing machine which has just uh
two states and three symbols on its tape
and um you know corchana have been
talking about you know hundreds of
symbols on the tape a person called alex
smith sort of proved this this thing
that i thought was true
about the fact that the very simplest
possible universal turing machine is two
colors three three uh two states three
colors
um and that was uh but any case so by
that time i think the turing machine was
sort of becoming the um
the lingua franca so to speak of the
emerging theoretical
computation
there were a few competitors registered
machines in the 1960s was something
where people would think talking about
you know compiler design when that was
kind of the the highest tech
of um of theoretical computer science i
think register machines were pretty
popular because they were and but they
they and then things that had more
random access memory kinds of models
because turing machines are like you
want to find that piece of data on the
tape well it's actually like an
old-fashioned tape drive you know like
you see in old movies and i remember
seeing in actual computers where you
would have these nine track tapes that
will be twitching back and forth and you
know as because what was happening was
data was written onto the tape and if
you wanted to find a piece of data that
had been written a while ago in a
different part of the tape the tape
actually had to you know spin around and
get to that point on the tape
um and that was that was kind of like a
touring machine
um
well
okay
it's some
uh
all right i probably should should wrap
up soon
um
but that's i think the story of of
touring machines and and maybe there was
an additional
uh
in 1970 when stephen cook
uh came up with np completeness the idea
of entry completeness that was another
kind of turing machine play to some
extent um that was another thing stated
in terms of non-deterministic turing
machines it's actually the first sort of
formalization i think of
non-deterministic turing machines turing
machines where it can take one of many
possible paths i mean i've subsequently
been very keen on this idea of multi-way
turing machines where it in a sense
takes all possible paths
but that's a different story
um
let's see
uh aaron is saying
like to read an essay about the printing
of the nks book yeah you know i i almost
wrote that actually maybe i should do
that now that it's the 20th anniversary
maybe i should write down what actually
happened i have all of the all the
materials it's kind of some wild things
there
good good idea i think i almost did that
at the 10th anniversary time time to do
it now
um
well there's a
question here
um
oh boy
oh there are a couple of really
interesting ones here all right one from
carob is it possible to identify the
moment in history when scientific
investigation as we know it broke away
from the study of philosophy
you know the early philosophers
particularly the pre-socratic
philosophers
a lot of what they thought philosophy
was about
was how do we describe the world what we
now call science
i think you know socrates and plato and
so on were big on the
you know
uh philosophy should also be about human
issues and human affairs
uh more so than about sort of the way
the world works kind of thing with the
way the physical world works
but people philosophers throughout
history
would have theories about how the world
works
and they would have theories about how
the world works how it relates to how
god works
because there was a lot of mixing
between theology and philosophy for a
long time
and
then
subsequently
i would say you know people might say
francis bacon was a person who
i think for perhaps partly political
reasons because quite a serious
politician kind of person was into the
you know let's do experimental science
and believe only what we can you know
what we can do experiments on but i
think the real dividing lines probably
galileo and newton
um i think that's where sort of the big
new idea of using math in a serious way
to build the structure of science came
in i mean the babylonians had used math
as a descriptive means to say you know
here's how to we can interpolate the
motion of planets things like that
um and um
but i think the time when math gets used
as a framework
more so than pure reasoning
is
around well galileo
you know 1630s things like that and then
1620s and then and then newton in
1687 um
this is uh you know newton's book his
principia you know it's principia
mathematica um well it's its full name
is um mathematical principles of natural
philosophy the study of physics had been
natural philosophy this was a book that
was kind of saying these are the
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy distinct from purely you know
descartes and people like this that had
theories of the world but they were
theories that were kind of more theories
constructed by thinking about the world
i mean descartes had also worked on
mathematics but i don't think he merged
those two in a very serious way and i
think he was still thinking about you
know vortices and
atoms and things
as a matter of the structure of the
world
not something where you can reason about
what's going on so i think that that
that's the time when the sort of
mathematical tradition of natural
science came in that's when sort of uh
science broke off from philosophy now
it's more difficult in other fields like
economics for example you know like uh
where i grew up in oxford there's uh a
lot of people learn you know the ppe
philosophy politics and economics you
know as one of the degree courses my
mother used to just to teach that stuff
she was a philosophy professor in oxford
um and uh the um you know that was in a
sense
things like quotes political science and
economic science which are now very
science-y presented things for a long
time were viewed as much closer to
philosophy and viewed as much more
fields where instead of you know going
down and
writing down a math formula or something
one was instead reasoning and more the
tradition of of uh of philosophy than
the tradition of of kind of the exact
sciences and mathematics and so on i
mean i think my own efforts actually in
in recent times it's been interesting
the extent it's sort of shocking to me
the extent to which some of the things
we're figuring out about sort of this
computational way of understanding the
world and this multi-computational
paradigm that i've recently been
developing um how those relate to kind
of questions in philosophy you know the
importance of consciousness
in in making sense of multi-computation
the uh questions like why does the world
why does the universe exist which i have
to say i i think i now have a pretty
decent handle on the answer to that
question and i've been kind of surprised
that to my knowledge surprising
philosophers
have decided that question is just too
hard
you know the why is there something
rather than nothing question has been
discussed a bit but not much in
philosophy and that one is interesting
because it is in some sense a very
philosophical question but it's actually
been considered too hard for philosophy
and i think we now have something of a
scientific answer a fairly interesting
scientific answer that can explain both
physics exists the universe exists why
it has to exist and mathematics also in
some sense exists and that relates to
these questions about foundations of
mathematics that i was alluding to
any case so i think the answer is late
1600s for most kinds of science
um uh you know i would say that there
are kinds of science that are still
uh quite uh more reasoning-based than
they are kind of formalism-based so to
speak
and in fact my own efforts in this kind
of multi-computational paradigm might
suggest some additional transitions that
could happen in the future
for some of these fields that
traditionally haven't had a good kind of
obviously scientific as opposed to
philosophical tradition for how they're
thought through i i must say that that
having you know i would not diss the
philosophical tradition because actually
i think in some cases people get drilled
down into the very scientific traditions
and actually completely lose sight of
the bigger questions in particular
fields of science and a little dose of
kind of more philosophical thinking more
kind of reasoning-based thinking would
be a really good thing
and i think also as we've understood
more about this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that i
first sort of started talking about in
the mid 1980s we're understanding the
extent to which some of these sort of
pure science approaches are necessarily
limited um and uh that that
sort of brings one back to these more
sort of reasoning based things
um
the um
uh
okay i i'll i'll talk i have talked i
think about the words of something
rather than nothing that's a slightly
complicated uh i mean i wrote a post
about it a few months ago that i
recommend i think it's fairly well
written um it's not a super simple topic
so i'm not going to try and um uh try
and cover it right now
okay there was one more question
all right let me try one last question
and then we should wrap up this is from
vikram
why do i think that certain cultures
have had such a disproportionate success
in science discovery and business
oh boy
you know
first of all
okay
there are
there are
there are kind of traditions that
develop i mean cultures are in a sense a
tradition of what's important what's not
important what we care about what we
don't care about
and some cultures have cared more about
intellectual scientific kinds of things
than others
now at some times in history one might
have said well that culture cares more
about science so what those guys are off
being eggheads you know doing their
science and intellectual stuff and so on
so what
you know what matters in the world
is having the best army what matters in
the world
is having the the the best devotion to
some particular uh religious direction
or whatever else who cares about all
this kind of eggheady sciencey stuff
it so happens that we live in a time in
history where the egg-headed sciences
stuff has been important and has been an
important part of kind of what's
determined kind of uh a lot of
what we get to use in technology and and
that's been you know if you look at the
course of human history and you say
what's changed you know you go look at a
greek play or something and you see
about the issues that they're discussing
and it's like that's human nature and
it's the same it's the exact same issues
with great precision it's the same
issues from a couple of thousand years
ago than today
what's changed since that greek play
came out well technology has changed
that's one very dramatic change there
have been some changes in in patterns
patterns of thought about organizing
society and things but not so much and
it's been kind of cyclical the one thing
that has a real flow is the invention of
things and technology and the kinds of
things that are possible in technology
and so that's given i think that kind of
uh that the the the sort of those who've
understood what it takes to make
technology has turned out to be a
disproportionately significant story of
of what different cultures deliver and i
think that that's you know that's part
of the reason
that that that that's been one of the
issues now there are other points like
there are some cultures where people
routinely
write books and publish them
where people
put their accomplishments and put them
on clay tablets like the babylonians did
we know what the babylonians did we
don't know what the phoenicians did you
know perhaps the phoenicians did great
things but they wrote everything on
papyrus and it's all gone now
the babylonians we happen to know what
they did because it was on clay tablets
now i suspect the babylonians were the
were the big ones for sort of the the
egg headery back in the day i mean you
know people uh the caldens as they're
often referred to in sort of more poetic
ways
um
uh you know people say i'm going to
consult the astrology they're they're
called the an astrologer and i'm going
to you know they're the mathematicians
and so on so probably the babylonians
really were
the a a a group that was um uh that
really had the significance that we
think they had today and it isn't just a
matter of who's whose tablets got
preserved so to speak why did the
babylonians do this well they were
building cities and when you build
cities you have to organize things and
you need to have land records and you
need to have systems of weights and
measures and things like this things
have to get kind of streamlined and i
think that's why the babylonians pushed
so hard to do those kinds of things now
at other times in history sort of
systematization has been something
important for for example empires like
you know there were times when the roman
empire was the sort of systematization
it's like you need to have a consistent
set of money and weights and measures
that extends across the empire so to
speak
and uh the same thing i mean i think uh
uh the british empire same kind of story
uh the us uh uh in so far as it's been a
dominant power for for the last hundred
years or so you know again a lot of kind
of defining of standards for the world
and i think those are things which again
the the the desire to do that
is um
uh is something that will drive a
certain amount of kind of um uh sort of
science-like thinking now you know the
other thing to say
it's a it's a it's an interesting
question particularly in indian and
chinese
uh uh
uh kind of um
uh science and so on uh you know there's
a lot of questions about what was found
out when
you know i was curious recently a
question that um
uh the idea of generative grammar the
idea that you can have sort of a
systematic recursive way of specifying
the grammar of of languages people say
that a person called panini who was a
uh indian living maybe in the few
centuries bc
invented such a grammar for sanskrit and
it's like well did he or didn't he and
so i started actually looking and it's
like well he's got these books that are
written as a bunch of aphorisms and
they're sort of examples templates of
grammar but i don't know did he really
invent this or not i i you know it takes
real work to sort of back project from
the way we're thinking about things
today to see what was really invented
back then
and it's a little different if there's a
sort of single thread of the way things
are presented if if it's presented as i
have many aphorisms well that's not the
way i don't know maybe maybe you could
say euclid is presenting sort of
aphorisms about the the axioms of
geometry but somehow we have a a
they're a little bit more formal perhaps
than these other kinds of aphorisms it's
hard to tell what was really there what
wasn't there it also doesn't help
that
those things tend to not to be dated so
it's just like well we have this thing
and we don't know whether it was from
the fourth century bc or the first
century a.d so there's a big sort of gap
there there's a big range there and in
terms of the flow of ideas you know uh
probably 10 years may not be much time
across sort of across the civilized
world but 100 years certainly is and so
you know in terms of figuring out what
happened when
um that's that's a a an issue there i
think that um you know when it comes to
these kind of cultural
things there are you know there are
cultural traditions when people really
cared about intellectual kinds of things
why
sometimes
there are you know religions that have
been more into let's go study the
details of the sacred book
versus
uh that's not the point and you know so
that will lead to different kinds of
emphasis on scholarship or not and these
are things that are uh the sort of in a
sense extraneous factors um it's not uh
that that sort of but eventually build
up to some kind of cultural direction
and i think the same is true you know in
business i mean one knows very well
from having done business around the
world that you know
globalist as as people might be
the fact is there's a lot of differences
between different countries and their
ways of doing business and the different
attitudes towards business you know
there are countries where the idea that
you start a company and it might fail is
like so horrifying that nobody starts
companies and there are other places
where it's like everybody's trying to
make a deal all the time and it's it's
hard to and you know and there's nothing
kind of fixed and it's everybody's doing
sort of custom bartering type deals and
that's just the way the culture is
and i think that it has you know it's a
big kind of
important question for for governments
and sort of economic development you
know why for example has the u.s been
such a dominant country
in in technology and particularly things
like software development relative to
other countries particularly software
development
you know it's one thing if you're making
microprocessors and you you understand
you know who understands the five
nanometer process or whatever and who
who has figured out you know how to
build this giant chain of machines that
eventually get you to that kind of
precision engineering that's something
that depends as a very history dependent
thing when it comes to software it's
just ideas
and you know it's much less obvious why
that should be concentrated in one place
rather than another and what you tend to
see
is there are very definite cultural
differences between the kinds of things
that people say that you know the
interface that will be kind of thought
to be cute and or cool or whatever in
one country is different from another
country um and i think you know the us
has had the advantage of having a large
domestic market
for
for software for example which has
helped it and that there's a lot of
other factors
but i think it's a uh i mean it's an
interesting fact that you know it's it's
more it's a more nurture than nature
story in terms of for example software
developments in the us because plenty of
people including myself
who have built software companies in the
us didn't come from the us
it's not something where it's like
something in the you know in the water
or something from um uh from from
earliest childhood or before or
something it's it's definitely a thing
about the environment that has caused
this to be possible in the us and not so
much in other places
but i think in terms of the development
of sort of the western tradition of
science and so on
you know it's partly that that tradition
happens to have fed very directly into
the technology the kinds of things that
have been successful in technology and
that's definitely elevated that
tradition over other ones and i think
that uh you know i'm much less
knowledgeable about other traditions i'm
you know i'm definitely a a uh western
uh you know
tradition kind of person in terms of of
science and other things about about
what i do so i'm i'm not not nearly as
familiar with other kinds of things
although people are always telling me
that ideas that i have and have talked
about in science resonate with
particularly various kinds of eastern uh
traditions um and i i it's very
interesting to me as i try to talk to
people about those kinds of things
because there comes a point at which i'm
like i just don't really quite get it
and it's kind of like you know i didn't
grow up in that tradition i'm just not
used to i don't have the the kind of the
mindset of thinking in those kinds of
terms and it's really hard to get there
and it's always a good reminder to me to
see that kind of thing because i've been
responsible for inventing i suppose a
few paradigms for thinking about stuff
and sometimes it's kind of like hey
everybody can't you understand this
stuff you know it's it's easy to
understand look i understand how this
works i can think in these terms and
it's like it's always good for me to be
reminded that there are sort of
paradigms where where you can present
them and i'm like i really don't get
this you know i can't reason in this
framework it just doesn't make sense to
me you know i can't conclude you know
anything you you give me all these sort
of uh pieces of some eastern tradition
and it's like and then say and what does
that mean for the world and what does
that mean for the nature of the world
and why the universe exists or something
and i'm like i don't know i can't tell i
can't reason in these in this framework
right
well i think um we should uh
wrap up there i think we've got some
good questions saved up for next time
but please do think of uh think of
things to ask i'm i'm really happy to uh
uh
to answer these things and as i say
answering these questions helps me
understand stuff so
i
i appreciate that very much
so thanks very much